he sees you when you are sleeping he
knows when you're awake he knows when
you've been bad or good so be good for
goodness sake if you live in the Western
world you already know this line from
Santa Claus is coming to town by Harry
Connick jr. we've all heard the songs
and seen the movies but you may not know
the true story behind the legend of the
man who can fly around the world in just
a single night and you might now be
wondering why am i wearing a hat that is
not a Santa Claus hat and that is
because for this very special Christmas
video I wanted to get a Santa Claus hat
but apparently I have a giant head and
this Christmas tree hat was the only
thing that would fit me I'm going to
take this off and we're gonna get on
with today's video Nicholas of Bari was
born in the fourth century in the town
of Myra located in Asia Minor this is
now modern-day Turkey his parents were
wealthy Christians who had trouble
conceiving a child for many years they
prayed to God every day to have a child
of their very own and as soon as they
finally conceived and gave birth to a
son they saw it as truly a miracle sadly
Nicholas as parents they would die of an
epidemic that had spread throughout the
city of Myra leaving him to become a
young orphan he was raised by his uncle
who was the Bishop of Myra who had never
had children of his own he was very
proud of his nephew especially when he
grew up to be a very well-behaved boy
his uncle apparently announced to
everyone in the church that he had a
vision that his nephew would grow up to
bring joy to many people when Nicholas
grew up his uncle's prophecy actually
did come true he was always kind to
others and went out of his way to help
people as an orphan Nicholas had a
special place in his heart for children
and he would often help them make
handmade toys to play with even though
he was from a wealthy family he still
had a lot of sympathy for the poor and
he wanted to do whatever he could to
help there was a man in the town who had
three beautiful daughters but he was so
poor he could not pay for a dowry this
meant that his daughters could not get
married and they would have to be sold
into slavery because the father could
not afford to support them Nicholas
wanted to help but he did not want to
hurt the father's pride by offering a
donation
face to face so he dropped a bag of gold
down the chimney which landed in their
stockings that were hanging up to dry
the father and his daughters that jumped
for joy believing that God had finally
answered their prayers he was finally
able to pay for the dowry and his oldest
daughter went on to get married Nicholas
came back to do this again for the two
younger daughters which is when he was
caught in the act
everyone knew this gold wasn't just
appearing out of thin air and people
began to whisper around town about a
young Nicholas and his kind heart and
his generosity Nicholas was a very
simple person who didn't need a lot to
be happy and the money didn't mean much
damn but he knew that his donations
could be life-changing for other
families in Myra he decided to continue
paying attention to people who needed
the most help in the city and he would
always anonymously give away as
inheritance to other people after this
story spread around town people began to
leave their stockings and shoes by the
fireplace in hopes that they would
receive gold from Nicholas as well
soon after this people throughout the
city of Myra were receiving anonymous
presents that would mysteriously appear
in their homes this sparked her spirit
of giving and neighbors were now helping
out one another in their time of need
without fear of hurting their pride any
time an anonymous gift would show up
they decided to thank Nicholas even if
he wasn't the ones who actually deliver
every single present people began a
rumor that since this man seemed to be
able to be in many places at once he was
more than just a devout Christian man
they believed that he had been blessed
with magical powers now he truly did
begin to travel across Turkey and he
reached a point where he had given away
all of his earthly possessions which was
totally fine with him he at that point
devoted his life to becoming a monk we
know with absolute certainty that
Nicholas truly was a real person because
he grew up to take over his uncle's
position as the next Bishop of Myra
there are records of his participation
the first Council of Nicaea including
his outspoken outrage over the
corruption that he saw within the
Catholic Church in one story Nicholas
witnessed a horrific scene where
children had been kidnapped and he was
then able to rescue them he was seen as
such a holy man that he was later
canonized as Saint Nicholas the patron
saint of children and surprisingly
sailors that's right Saint Nick a lofty
traveled even back then he sailed along
the coasts of Asia Minor and dreamed of
seeing
the entire planet for years to come
sailors would continue to pray to San
Nicolas to help them whenever they were
on a long voyage legend has it that one
day Turkish sailors were out at sea and
the winds and waves were so strong that
the men were afraid that the boat would
capsize they prayed to San Nicolas for
help and he appeared before them with
his arms outstretched he was able to
control the weather and calm the ocean
and the sailors made it home safely this
was just one of the many examples of the
stories of Saint Nick's extraordinary
magical powers and it just may be a good
explanation of how Center manages to
travel in his sleigh through all kinds
of weather the fantastical stories of
cynical us lasted for longer than just
one lifetime his story continued to go
on for another thousand years it would
seem that the magic behind his
generosity was so inspiring and powerful
it was enough to keep him alive in the
hearts of mankind for generations to
come from the fourth to the 16th
centuries Nicholas became one of the
most popular Catholic saints people
continued to pray to him
wishing for his help in their time of
need as time went on he preferred to
receive letters rather than prayers it
was probably much easier for him to keep
records this way stories of cynics magic
and generosity began to spread
throughout the rest of the world in the
Netherlands Belgium and Switzerland
children began to leave their shoes
outside on San Nicholas Day so that is
the jolly Sinterklaas could leave them
presents sure enough small toys and
candy were left for them when they awoke
in the morning after the Protestant
Reformation Martin Luther wanted to do
away with the stories of Catholic saints
so he said that these presents were
actually coming from the baby Jesus or
Christ candle people were confused of
course because they knew that the real
gift giver was the jolly old Saint Nick
delivering the presents to these
children so a Christ candle was
misunderstood to be Kris Kringle earns
the nickname stock after the
Revolutionary War there was a movement
to reject many of the English ways and
start new traditions that were uniquely
American an author by the name of
Washington Irving had already made a
name for himself by writing and
publishing American folktales that had
been told by word-of-mouth like Rip Van
Winkle and the spooky Legend of Sleepy
Hollow
this became
classic so when he heard about the Dutch
story of Sinterklaas he decided to
officially give him the properly
American sounding name Santa Claus this
is how cynic officially became a part of
the American Christmas tradition over
the next few hundred years the public
would learn more about Santa Claus than
they ever had known before in 1809
Irving wrote in his book knickerbockers
history of New York about a surprising
santa sighting in Central Park it read
the goodson Nicholas came riding over
the tops of the trees in that self-same
waggon wearing he brings his yearly
presents to children he went on to
explain that Santa took a break to smoke
his pipe of tobacco before getting back
in his wagon and flying away fortunately
as he might imagine modern Santa has
given up smoking but he has replaced it
with a serious cookie addiction so it's
not exactly kind on his ever-expanding
waistline as the years went on more and
more writers would elaborate with
additional details about Santa Claus in
December of 1823 a writer named Clement
Clarke Moore was walking through the
snow on his way home
under his arm he had a Christmas turkey
for his family and looking around at the
beautiful scene he was suddenly inspired
to write a poem entitled a visit from
Sanok Ellis but you probably know that
as the night before Christmas twas the
night before Christmas when all through
the house not a creature was stirring
not even a mouse the stockings were hung
by the chimney with care in the hopes
that said Nicholas would soon be there
this became an incredibly popular poem
it's so perfectly captured the Christmas
spirits that in just a few years nearly
every American would know it by heart
instead of thinking of his time living
in Turkey as a fourth century Saint
people now imagine Santa Claus to be a
chuddy a jolly old man who climbed
through the chimney to place presents in
stockings and leave them wrapped up
under the Christmas tree
so Nick had always been a sailor and an
avid traveler throughout his lifetime
navigating the open sea is no easy task
especially before the benefits of GPS
but he wanted to get around on land at a
much faster pace in 1821 an anonymous
author wrote and illustrated a story
called old Santa Claus with much delight
for the first time the public learns
that Center had upgraded his ride from a
rickety old wagon and a boat to a proper
sled pulled by a single reindeer in a
in 89 poet Katherine Lee Bates
introduced the world to mrs. Claus and
we got to know a little bit more about
some Nick's personal life we still don't
know exactly when they got married but
this couple have what is probably the
longest lasting marriage in history we
also don't know if they ever had any
children together as the years went on
the public learned more about Santa's
progress in his mission to bring joy to
the world we learned that he moved his
new secret hideout to the North Pole and
he hired a team of elves to run his
workshop we were introduced to his
extended fleet of eight magic reindeer
and in 1939 he added to the newest
member of the team Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer in 1891 even the President of
the United States was promoting Santa
Claus Benjamin Harrison told the press
we shall have an old-fashioned Christmas
tree for the grandchildren upstairs and
I shall be their Santa Claus myself
that's me hope that my example will be
followed by every family in the land the
very first video footage ever captured
of Santa Claus was in 1898 by a
filmmaker named GA Smith the world could
see him leaving presents for sleeping
children on Christmas Eve of course as
time went on and modern technology
improved more and more people were
capturing footage of Santa Claus it was
finally time for him to come out of
hiding and make his first public
appearances
moving into the 20th century santa claus
was always hip to the modern times
during the industrial revolution he was
able to improve his operations with his
elf employees working the assembly lines
in his workshop at the North Pole sound
of a game more like the CEO of his toy
empire making sure the operation run as
smoothly as possible
now that he wasn't running his workshop
alone he was finally able to make the
time to begin making public appearances
in 1924 he decided to be a part of the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade in New
York City he received such a warm
welcome from his adoring fans that he
decided to reappear every single year
ever since so long as the organizers
meet the demand on his rider to provide
in a tall glass of milk and some warm
chocolate chip cookies in the green room
the 1980s brought the boom of the
shopping mall in the United States and
this began the tradition of Santa Claus
taking personal requests from boys and
girls there is even the massive particle
SantaCon held every year in New York
City which isn't even a real convention
it's just an excuse to dress acent Negin
party in the streets there is also the
Liverpool Santa - and so many other
events all around the world that are
thrown in his honor moving into the 21st
century modern technology has helped us
truly break down the science of just how
Santa manages to make his journey you
can track some Nicks progress on Google
Maps as Santa tracker and in 2016 the
mirror did an intensive study of the
statistics of Santa's magical journey on
Christmas Eve they discovered that in
order for him to deliver presents you
every single child in the world on a
single night he would need to travel at
speeds of 1,280 miles per second even
though the world loves Santa Claus that
doesn't mean his legacy has been free
from controversy indeed he is often
blamed for being at the root of making
the holiday season about material things
rather than having young people remember
the true meaning of Christmas
commercialism is a very real thing of
course and there is no denying that
Santa Claus has helped sell billions of
dollars in products every holiday season
from coca-cola to Barbie dolls but in a
world where religion and politics divide
so many people there are very few things
that Americans agree on quite like the
tradition of Santa Claus every December
the 24th children go to bed and they
wake up at the crack of dawn
hoping
they will find presents underneath the
Christmas tree for many it's one of the
very few memories we all share of having
faith in something and the experience of
childhood wonder and the belief in magic
but sometimes Santa Claus can't do
everything by himself and he needs to
recruit help in unexpected ways just one
example of this was in 2011 a young
couple named Jim and Dillon moved into
their new apartment on West 22nd Street
in New York City then they started to
get letters in their mailbox addressed
to Santa Claus they thought it was a
joke of course and they went to the post
office to see if there was a forwarding
address for the previous tenants they
were told that yes there was but it was
simply put as the North Pole at first
they didn't know what to do with these
letters since they had no idea how these
random children got their address
they even thoroughly searched for why on
Google eventually they decided that they
could not ignore these matters many of
them were harboring matters that came
from underprivileged children Dylan and
Jim began to parcel letters to their
friends and co-workers who all shared in
the responsibility of buying presents
for these kids soon enough word spread
on Facebook and they were able to get
hundreds of letters fulfilled by
kind-hearted volunteers they now run a
charity called miracle on 22nd Street
where anyone can volunteer to help out
with the letters to Santa if you're
still unconvinced in the existence of
Santa Claus there are few words that can
better express the truth than those of
Francis for Sullust Church in 1897 an 8
year old girl named Virginia a Hanlon
wrote to the New York Sun saying that
her friends in school told her that
Santa Claus was not real she asked the
church to tell her the truth and they
published this reply yes Virginia there
is a Santa Claus he exists as sure as
generosity and devotion exists and you
know they abound and give to your life
its highest beauty and joy alas how
dreary the world would be without a
Santa Claus and just hear a biographic
Sui want to say that Santa Claus does
exist as long as he's in our house and
with that very Merry Christmas
[Music]